One of the things that this documentary
has really implanted in my brain is that things take time.
They take time to realize you're not in a good situation.
They take time.
And one of the problems is in the legal situation
is this statute of limitations.
And that it's one to three years
In California, it was one to three years.
It was.
Mm-hmm.
You work so hard on yourself,
but then you work so hard for other people,
and you go and you start this journey
of legally trying to change the system
because you so eloquently explain
that it takes time for people to realize
that they've been a victim,
that they've been gaslit, to have the bravery.
You have written now what is called the Phoenix Act
and you have changed legislation in California,
which is incredible.
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
What was the moment that you said,
"I am willing to do this
not just for myself, but other people?"
It was when I found out there were other people,
and this is the part that actually
makes me the most emotional is when I talk
about how desperately people need help.
When I first started speaking about my abuse,
I was still sort of in the midst of processing it.
When I testified in front of Congress
for another bill for the sexual assault survivor's
bill of rights, I thought that was gonna be it,
I thought that was gonna be the only time
I told my story, thought was gonna leave it there,
walk away, move on.
And then I saw, after I testified,
all these stories popping up on the internet,
and when I saw that, it was like a bomb went off
and I could tell by the details in their stories,
they knew things that nobody else knew.
I knew they were telling the truth.
And there was this amazing moment of liberation,
I'm not crazy.
All of the thing, the way this person gaslit me,
anytime I question them, anytime I challenge them,
the way they made me feel like I was so wrong,
and I was so unhinged.
And then to see that I was right,
like I can trust myself.
I wasn't, I see now the truth.
(upbeat music)